here we go from Engadget Twitter
confirms it intends to close deal with
Elon Musk Twitter has again agreed to
let Elon Musk buy the company they say
the agreement follows months of legal
drama after musk tried to back out of
his original agreement to buy the
company for 44 billion dollars this
spring the two sides were set to go to
trial later this month as Twitter
attempted to force must keep up his end
of the agreement musk had claims Twitter
had misled him about the number of bots
on the platform and had raised concerns
about issues disclosed by the company's
former head of security who fell The
Whistleblower complaint
so Twitter investor relations tweets
Twitter issued this statement about
today's news we have received a letter
from the musk parties which they have
filed with the SEC the intention of the
company is to close the transaction at
54 and 20 cents per share the question
why did Elon Musk try backing out
go into this big legal drama and then
abruptly just agree to the original sale
price